when i first came out i never envisioned
uh
even being loved by anybody i was still
afraid
i lived in fear still you know there's
people all on the beach here
and you seem comfortable something i was
always
afraid about you know being seen with a
man
but i realized there's nothing wrong
with our love
you know so being out here people
looking at us
i really don't mind because i have you
and that's all i mean
it's just amazing to be free to open my
wings and be free
i'm proud of you
the world has come a long way and even
though
maybe that your mom and dad aren't as
progressed
you deserve happiness and any roadblocks
that happen
we'll bust right through them together
yeah that's for sure
thank you for that armando still has to
talk to his parents and let them know
that we're getting married
i'm not sure if they think it's really
going to happen he's never mentioned a
wedding happening since he told them
that we were engaged he's unsure of what
their reaction will be
if they would even come to the wedding
and that's heartbreaking
[Music]
and look what we have here your next
surprise
wow oh my god really
we're gonna ride horses oh you planned
all this yes yeah she did
babe wow
you got me surprised yes it's amazing
i've always envisioned like a wonderful
romantic time on the beach
you know couples riding off in the
sunset in the movies on the horses and i
thought we would look cool doing that
it made me think of a gay move oh shut
up
you ready all right i can't quit you
okay let's go you sure you got this got
it
to finally come here and celebrate and
be free
although every step of the way has been
a struggle
it's all been worth it and i wouldn't
change a single thing because i'm where
i know i'm supposed to be